Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
The super-popular Angry Birds game has been
catapulted on to the big screen to give us
The Angry Birds Movie!
Cue 97 minutes of bright and breezy colours,
zany action, and briskly-paced comedy, which
will doubtless keep kids entertained while
providing enough jokes aimed at adults in
the audience to keep grown-ups happy too.
The crazy and somewhat slight story revolves
around the avian paradise of Bird Island where
all the birds are happy, except for Red, who
gets pretty annoyed about everything, including
the arrival of a bunch of green pigs to the
island.
Now, you don't need to have played the game
before to understand what's going on or to
enjoy the movie.
As you'd probably expect though, whether you're
an Angry Birds addict or a total newcomer,
there's a stack of bird- and pig-related puns
throughout the film.
One-liners, sight gags, slapstick, and some
gross-out humour fly by thick and fast, some
of the jokes hitting, some not.
There's also quite a number of rather fun
easter eggs and pop culture references and
I'll have a video on that coming soon.
I'll add the link here so you can click there
to see it when it's ready!
The movie's voice cast contains a wealth of
familiar faces hidden behind their animated
avian and swinish characters.
Jason Sudeikis, Danny McBride, and Josh Gad
are entertaining as feathered friends Red,
Bomb and Chuck, who meet at an anger-management
class run by Matilda, who's voiced by Bridesmaids
star Maya Rudolph.
Sean Penn gets to grunt his way through the
movie as the intimidatingly gruff Terence.
Inside Out's Bill Hader plays the pig's wickedly
cunning leader Leonard with real glee.
While Game of Thrones star Peter Dinklage
has an amusing role as the once-heroic Mighty
Eagle.
In fact, the voice cast is littered with well-known
names from comedy including Keegan-Michael
Key, Ike Barinholtz from The Mindy Project,
Veep's Tony Hale, SNL's Kate McKinnon, Tituss
Burgess from Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt, and
lots more.
It's a shame that many of their roles are
so small and that the film flies by so frenetically
that a number of them don't get to really
register or make a real impact.
First-time directors Fergal Reilly and Clay
Kaytis and their team of animators have done
a great job creating incredibly appealing
colourful characters.
While The Angry Bird Movie doesn't hit the
animated heights of the best of Pixar or Disney,
or The Lego Movie, say, it's still a good
deal of fun.
So, to sum up: The Angry Birds Movie is lively,
entertaining, and bursting at the seams with
quality voice cast, anarchic attitude, and
a barrage of jokes.
While it's not the animated equivalent of
a gourmet meal to be lingered over, it's certainly
a tasty fast-food treat.
The Angry Birds Movie gets 3 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, what did you think of The Angry Birds
Movie?
And if you've played the Angry Birds game,
did you like the way they adapted it for the
big screen?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this review, I'd love it if you'd
share it, and do subscribe for more movie
reviews, Easter Egg videos and amazing movie
facts!
Click the links here to check those out!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!